day of mourning in the russian republic
of tata stan as its capital kazan
comes to terms with the horrific mass
shooting at a local school
nine people were killed most of them
children while more than 20 others were
injured
the sight of the tragedy has now become
a makeshift memorial with thousands of
locals commemorating those lost
here's a timeline of how the shocking
events unfolded
[Music]
i was in the class on the second floor
we heard bangs that sounded like
explosions
first we closed the classroom doors and
did not let the children get near the
windows
we told them to sit down along the walls
and try to calm them down
a man with a gun ran into the classroom
and started shooting people
he didn't shout anything but before he
did this we heard an explosion right
under our classroom
after that our teacher told us to hide
under the desks
[Music]
foreign
numerous ambulances emergency crews and
fire trucks
were at the site later i saw a teacher
covered in blood
getting pulled out of the school and
about four children being carried away
[Music]
artist right gazdev has been following
the tragic events from kazan he reports
now on the day of mourning currently
being observed in the city which is
still in a state of shock
well as you would expect the city's
heart has been
shattered today may be a day of mourning
but it lasted throughout the night
there's tens of thousands literally tens
of thousands of people flocked to these
small
makeshift memorials burying them with
flowers with toys
in memory of those who had died
yesterday the horrific
attack yesterday long before their time
long long before their time
seven pupils as well as two teachers
many others are still in hospital
several of them in horrific condition i
mean if you read the list of injuries
you can understand what sort of
nightmare took place
in this school yesterday as a
nine-year-old for example with
multiple gunshot wounds shotgun wounds
to the chest
who lost three liters of blood he's
fighting for his life
as well as well as others who have
gunshot wounds to their backs to their
legs
broken hips glass wound shrapnel cuts to
the face and neck as they
in pandemonium and chaos and panic as
they jumped from windows
uh down three stories to get away from
the chaos to get away from the shooting
there's all sorts of videos online
showing students hunkered down behind
desks as
teachers stand guard next to barricade
the doors
but the headmistress shouting into the
loudspeaker system for people
to get in the cover for teachers to
close doors
not open them for anyone we have frantic
calls to parents
we have parents all over the city
literally sprinting running
along streets to schools because of
messages that there may be attacks
in other schools to safeguard their kids
to get them out of classes to make sure
everything's fine
it was a scene of absolute chaos here in
kazan
yesterday things only calmed down
towards towards the evening when the
suspect was
apprehended and authorities calm people
down urging them to remain calm that
everything is
under control obviously the people here
many of them have kids many of them had
kids yesterday in school so
they were worried they were concerned
they were in fear in terror
of what what happened that what could
happen you know although all the
messages were frightening online on the
internet
and all the people here they're here to
express their support for those who are
still
fighting for their lives in hospital and
again for those who lost their lives in
the tragic attack
that took place yesterday it was
somewhat rarity i have two kids myself
two sons what can i feel now i feel
awful
i came here from the other side of town
just so i could see this place
so i could place a toy in flowers
when i heard the news i burst into tears
i have two children
one of them is a schoolboy and when i
imagine what the children from the
gymnasium went through
i feel very bad
the neighborhood is quite calm we did
not expect
we are very surprised that we had such
an attack we can say that we are in
shock i was at work
what people obviously want now is
answers
answers about how this was allowed to
happen why no red
flags were raised when a 19 year old
bought a shotgun how he was given a
valid a real license
how he passed all the psychiatric tests
the drug test the medical evaluation
the background check how this person was
able to buy
350 reportedly 350 rounds of ammunition
for his shotgun
without raising any red flags this is a
person who lives in the middle of a city
why this person you know is described as
intelligent calm
quiet without without any sort of red
flags what pushed him
to carry out this this inhuman act
and what authorities are going to do
about it you know three years ago i
reported from kerch
where another school shooting took the
lives of unfortunately many more
children and
people thought that lessons had been
learned security had been established by
law
at schools all over the country and yet
there are
gaps gaps in security here there are
already huge shortcomings in the
security at the school
as well as perhaps what people suspect
shortcomings in the work of law
enforcement agencies
nevertheless it is early to jump to
conclusions the investigation has
only begun but people here want answers
frank garcia reporting that the kazan
shooting suspect has been identified as
a 19 year old it later came to light
he was a former student of the school
where the attack happened the
perpetrator used a
pump action shotgun for which he had a
legal license
after cctv footage emerged online though
it turns out the suspect was brazenly
carrying that
gun in question all the way on the
journey to school and we could take a
look at the route here that he
reportedly took
from his house to the school it's a
journey by foot that would have taken
just
over 10 minutes however questions remain
as to why no passes by called the police
to alert them that there was somebody
walking around
with a gun clearly visible it's one of a
number of issues the incidents raised
including what might have led the
suspect to carry out such an attack
those who knew him said it went totally
against his character
we met this boy before he's our neighbor
and i remember his face
i noticed that he had a very intelligent
appearance he was very tidy
i've never seen him heading out with any
dubious people he was a good boy
and was always so quiet he also helped
me in the past with the tata language
i don't know why he became like this i
don't know what happened to him they are
a very good and well-mannered family i
only had a good opinion of him
you